the Galapagos cormorants is a flightless
fever compared to other cormorants which
can fly it has short waist and a reduced
chest
there aren't many land predators in the
isolated Galapagos Island cormorants
don't need to fly away from threats so
selection has removed the need for big
wings and breast cells but how does
evolution make these changes
researchers sequence the Galapagos
cormorant a no to find out how its
flightlessness evolved they found
changes in the function of hair like
cellular structures called cilia one
gene in particular involved in
regulating cilia was missing a small
piece found in all other birds and
mammals cilia on cells called
chondrocytes have on important signals
during development these signals are
needed for both to fully mature in both
birds and humans this function appears
to be delayed in the cilia of Galapagos
cormorant
similar mutations caused diseases in
humans called pili Apogee's which can be
linked with shorter arms and reduced
chest this research suggests a route for
flightlessness to evolve rapidly and for
these birds to become the ideal Island
dwelling swimmers
[Music]
you
[Music]